Jason, Sam, congratulations.
You guys are moving
on to the third round
of this competition,
based solely
on the strength of your blades.
And that's going to play out
very nicely, because, now we're
sending you back
to your home forges
to recreate one of
these, the spiked mace.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in four days.
My general game
plan today is to forge
and heat treat the spikes.
So I got a half inch
round of 4142 steel.
That needs to be
forged down smaller
and then put the point on it.
I'm forging them really quick.
I can do them each
in about one heat.
I'm heating up my two
rods at the same time.
So while I'm working one, the
other one can be heated up.
What'll happen next is I'll
forge a little tail end
and that's what's going
to go into the ball.
This was provided by the judges.
I drill the holes on the
center line of the ball.
And I'm just getting so excited.
So I put some spikes in.
And this thing looks bad ass.
That's pretty damn cool.
It's day one.
We're at my home forge
for OTH Forge and Foundry.
Today, I'm going to be
forging out 25 spikes.
If I can get all 25 finished,
then I'm going to be well
set up and ahead of the game.
We got one done.
First spike's ready.
I'm using the S7 steel,
because it has an incredibly
high impact
resistance, which lends
itself to a bludgeoning weapon.
There we go.
Mace spike's done.
So now, I'm going
to mechanically
attach it to the ball.
Now I'm setting up
my mill to attempt
to drill and tap the spikes.
I'm going to tap each one of
the spikes out individually,
thread them on stock,
and use that to attach
it to the ball head.
The most concerning
point for me is just
how strong that connection is.
If something goes
wrong, it's going
to be a spike breaking off.
Nope.
The spike is too hard for
this drill bit to cut into.
I need to get each one of
the 25 individual spikes
attached to the head.
One more time.
I'm gonna tap each
one of the spikes
out individually to attach
it to the ball head.
No.
Two bits down, not
taking down a third one.
Weld them on.
Move on to plan B.
Attach the threads
with just a basic bead weld.
Weld holds-- you
actually have no idea
how happy that makes me.
So I'm starting off today
mounting the rest of the spikes
to the other half of the ball.
The fit of these spikes,
what I'm going to be doing
is putting them through half
of my ball, heating up the end,
and actually riveting it over
on the inside of the ball.
So these spikes are
gonna go nowhere.
Making progress.
Only 20 hours left.
Doesn't feel like a ton of time.
Done with all the spikes.
But I think I'll be
able to get done.
You could definitely do
some damage with this.
Today, I need to attach
the spikes head the mace.
After that, it's
gonna be working
on the guard, the pommel.
Everything fits.
And I want to
break a few things.
That passed the test
really, really easy.
It was a long, very
hard day, but I'm
very happy with the results.
I got a lot done yesterday.
Pretty much just
got to do my handle.
What this project needs
is a [inaudible] figure
8 guard and a knuckle bow.
That looks freaking awesome.
I'm really, really pleased
with how that guard turned out.
Typically, I try
to make whatever
I'm making aesthetically
pleasing as possible.
So I decided to put some
decorative little grooves
in my knuckle bow.
Time to rivet it all together.
I got my knuckle bow
made out of mild steel.
And I'm attaching it
with copper rivets, disk
pommel with a wrought iron cap.
It's as secure as I
could've hoped for all.
I have left to do is
put on a leather wrap
and this project is a wrap.
The first thing
I'm gonna do today
is drill a hole through the
head, through the shaft,
and out the other
side of the head,
in order to pin this head
into place against the shaft.
I've already welded
the head to the shaft,
but I want to make sure this
ball isn't going anywhere.
That's a spiky murderball.
All right, bladesmiths,
welcome to the Kill Test.
To find out what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do,
I will take your
spike mace and deliver
some killing blows on this
unsuspecting ballistics dummy.
Jason, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Absolutely.
Let's do this.
[bleep].
All right, Jason, let's talk
about your spiked mace here.
Your handle construction
fits in my hand nicely.
It is a cylindrical handle,
but it's nice enough
to where I can hold on to it.
There's a good grip to that.
Now, this thing, like you
said, is a murder weapon.
It crushes with every strike.
But in so doing, some
of the spikes came off.
There's about five
pieces missing on this.
But overall, sir, without a
doubt, and a big headache,
it'll kill.
All right, Sam.
It's your turn.
You ready?
- Yes.
Let's do this.
All right, Sam.
Let's talk about
your spike mace here.
First up, it's a crusher.
It's a heavy forward
weapon, that when
you're thrusting with it,
it does penetrate easily.
Now, there's an issue here.
Your handle, it gets in the
way, especially with a very
forward heavy weapon.
You could potentially hurt
the person wielding it,
which unfortunately
prevents it from being
a fully functional weapon.
But despite that, this
is a sharp weapon.
This definitely is something
that will crush and it'll kill.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to our strength test.
I'm gonna take your weapons.
And I'm gonna play a
little terracotta baseball.
Two things to
remember, it's not what
your weapon does to the jars.
I want to see what the jars
are gonna do to your weapons.
And number two, I'm gonna
be swinging for the fences.
Jason, you're up.
You ready?
Let's do it.
Let's go.
You see, on your
head, you've got
some of these nubs that have
clay in them, some that don't.
The ones that don't,
broke on the pots.
So you lost a few more spikes.
That being said though,
it's comfortable.
I can keep swinging this
weapon for quite a while.
Even if more spikes came off,
this is still a deadly weapon,
because you got the ball
on here with the nubs
and your main spike.
Overall, good job.
Hey, Sam.
- Hey.
- You ready?
Oh, yeah.
OK.
I think my spikes
are gonna hold up,
but I'm really concerned
about my handle.
It's already hurt Doug.
I don't want any more of the
judges to hurt themselves.
We'll see what happens.
Sam, in the world of
weapons and warriors,
a weapon should be
feared by your enemy,
not by the warrior
who wields it.
Because that pommel
is so out of scale
and inflicted so much harm to
Doug in that first kill test,
that in the strength test
we just can't take the risk
of injuring one of our judges.
And for that reason, I'd like to
invite you to shake our hands,
shake your competitors hand,
and then please leave the forge.
It looks fantastic, man.
I'm not surprised
at the judge's ruling.
I totally agree
with what they said.
I may not be the Forged
in Fire Champion,
but I got to use
the power hammer.
And I got to make an
excellent blade and cool mace.
So I'm really happy.
Jason, your weapon has
elevated you to the title
of Forged in Fire Champion.
And you'll be receiving
a check for $10,000.
Good job, brother.
I'm absolutely astounded.
I won.
I feel very, very lucky
and so very thankful.
Being the Forged
in Fire Champion
means that it
validates my skills.
And I'm able to
look at my children
and I can say,
follow your dreams.
Chase them.
You can achieve anything.